think that there was a bit of a  bait-and-switch that happened with this  album when we put out look what you made  me do and were like guys this albums  gonna be one thing and when the album  came out it's legitimately an album  about finding love throughout all the  noise and so it starts with the noise  and how that all makes you feel and how  it makes you feel when like when people  are saying things about you that you  feel like aren't true and and living  your life sort of in defiance of that in  defiance of your reputation and then  it's sort of in the middle of the album  you kind of realize okay so so what  how much do I really value that like if  if you can find something real in spite  of a bad reputation then isn't that what  matters the most to you and is doesn't  it matter the most to you that you know  who your real friends are now  [Applause]  [Music]